[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is just a fun little flashback video
1993. that was 20 years ago i was born
in 1993 uh and that's quite a long time
ago in tech terms i mean 20 years from
now will be in 2033 so we'll have you
know the iphone 25s or something i mean
it's a long time from now so a lot can
happen in technology in 20 years uh 20
years ago in 1993 att was a pretty big
company still and they made this random
sort of futuristic commercial it's the
first link in the description below the
like button on this video and it is
definitely worth a watch in fact let's
go ahead and watch it together this is
the commercial at t put out 20 years ago
in 1993.
[Applause]
have you ever borrowed a book
from thousands of miles away
across the country
without stopping for directions
[Music]
or send someone a fax
from the beach
you will
and the company that'll bring it to you
a t and t
uh
what what
in 1993 how did they know this in 1993
who made this commercial for at t in
1993. have you ever borrowed a book from
thousands of miles away i literally just
did on my phone like a couple minutes
ago have you ever crossed the country
without stopping to ask for directions i
actually did that a week ago literally
seven days ago i did that too and have
you ever sent someone a fax from the
beach well if you replace the word facts
with email or text
or tweet or direct message or anything
else
yes i have and the company to all bring
it to you at t well okay so they didn't
they didn't get that part right but to
be honest they got way more right than
they should have they actually got
hardware designs right they got designs
right they got implementations right
they got way more right than pretty much
any other company would have even
thought of or dreamed of getting close
to in 1993 so this was a tv commercial
actually and att aired it on tv between
tv shows and everything like any other
normal commercial and this is 20 years
ago back when computers looked like this
and the internet was basically just a
bunch of a couple thousand lucky people
that actually had access to it and it
was basically used for just sending
messages back and forth between each
other in fact sixty percent of internet
traffic in 1993 was email
now it's not now uh
60 of internet traffic is definitely not
email but reading a book on the internet
first of all that's a thing that happens
today that's been happening for the past
couple of years and in fact google books
is what i use and you can read and sync
books on the internet right now and dude
she touched the screen like she touched
the screen that's like a desktop touch
screen pc like we see windows 8 desktop
touchscreen pcs just coming around now
in like the late 2010s to like now
that's pretty impressive that they
already kind of saw that coming
and google books on a windows 8 desktop
touchscreen pc is like now a thing so
that's pretty impressive att also
figured that if we were going to
navigate across the country without
asking for directions that we would need
an in-dash touchscreen car mounted gps
system that narrates us directions in
real time
that is a hundred percent accurate you
have to remember that cars in 1993 look
nothing like they do now or at least the
inside did the interior was all analog
there was no digital you know no touch
screens no displays or anything sort of
digital at all inside of cars in 1993
very few buttons that we see today and
now it already knows that we're going to
be using things even the interface that
kind of showed was kind of similar to
what i'd expect to even see in the next
few years from now pretty crazy and
finally the dude at the end of the video
sends a handwritten message digitally to
someone from the beach
again touch screen stylus fluid
interface 3g connectivity it's it's
looking a lot like the galaxy tab 10.1
does obviously they didn't get the form
factor quite right kind of looks like a
freaky fat device but you obviously
can't predict that stuff but they got
the idea right they got the
implementation right and that's a
product that we see today the samsung
galaxy tab 10.1 lte does exactly that
right now so you win 18 t either way you
you just took the w you win
i'm going to definitely watch all your
futuristic style commercials very
carefully from now on so that i can know
exactly what the world's going to be
like in 2033. either way what do you
guys think what do you think of the
world in 2033 are we seeing it in
commercials now flying cars or just
google wallet everywhere what does their
future kind of hold i know there's a lot
of kind of silly robotic themed droid
commercials that we're seeing kind of
phase out from the motorola days but
honestly a lot of the stuff is pretty
interesting and i'm excited to see if
anything
at least awesome looking like google
glass kind of makes its way forward
for our future so either way let me know
in the comment section below what you're
excited for
and i'll definitely go watch some att
commercials now because
i'm excited thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you